john monde sait ce que l'on se retrouve
sur genzyme 4 just dance 4 avec la
kinect
excusez-moi si la qualité de ma voix
n'est pas génial génial mais c'est parce
que le micro est un petit peu moins deux
mois le micro montrer ton est cassé donc
voilà le micro est sur le bureau juste
là j'espère que ce sera pas trop trop
trop dégueulasse
quoi qu'il en soit ce sera mes plumes
écrou la caméra alors c'est parti on va
commencer direct aux îles magnifiques on
va rigoler
non merde ok j'espère que ça va bien
marcher en ce moment bouffon vert en
rouge on est trop darche au métro des
oufs ainsi que des lycées touchés
chiffre là c'est parti
allez chiche aux fruits au micro ces
sauvages
allez on fait des perfect je sais pas
c'est quoi un signe en bas à droite
possible
[Musique]
ce n'est pas parfait mais c'est le choix
de avec le choc à perte est de faire le
show j'aime autant supprimer de joie on
est perplexe
il aime quand je me dérange comme ça
[Musique]
personne n'en voudrait pas comme ça mais
ce que je sais c'est que l'emploi tillon
des jumelles à dos c'est la solution
comme des gros je suis deuxième est une
journée relais par le haut allez allez
[Musique]
je ne sais quoi c'est toujours sous
l'épée c'est énorme a souligné
[Musique]
c'est le monde
chaud
la superbe fille comme elle a way with
maintenant
je ne vais pas lui aussi nommé parce que
j'adore ça
[Musique]
regarde c'est moi qu'on soit tous les
jours
je ne fais pas au tout seul je fais moi
on s'était presque pas de penser je suis
désolé alors tu balances arabe
lesquels
mais je développe déjà fort le mec il
fait 3 0 en commun
comme j'ai encore juste pour c'est fini
ah [ __ ] j'en peux plus comme maire de
fées premier avance merci merci merci
des fans merci a bientot salut grave et
continue au grand alès parti continuer
franchement les kleenex et bien foutu
bon là j'avoue tu fais n'importe quoi tu
as des bonnes notes c'est un porte-voix
auto dance ou annonce afin mouvement bon
allez allez on va attendre
moi je suis fatigué mon dieu c'est le
cas pour la deuxième pour pour faire les
gens qui ont du style bohème et une
casquette et là oh mon dieu c'est donc
cette marque pour cela on peut faire des
excuses ça marche on jure qu allah au
moins chaque personne ayant ce jeu et la
kinect a testé je suis sûr de faire un
doigt à voir si ces marchés ça ne marche
pas comme ça peut-être
et si on fait ça
tu es nul je suis plus là à l'automne et
cela qu'est ce que c'est à je sens le
truc bien qu'on le truc bien débile
arriver là oui le truc vraiment nul
partagez ce faire
[Musique]
à l'amicale hanche et
allah
on a tout vu mais tu arrives pas
ok bon allez hop retour on s'en fout
c'est d'ignorer le vrai plus alors
continué à lancer une deuxième effacé
caution sans phosphore des droits les
allées mojo pour débloquer des trucs
sûrement voilà un mec juste 300 points
2/4 est heureux que jean roch intrigue
débrouiller bon on va faire une table
sur son techno là haut
oh là là alors je dis ça tombe sur the
chanson électro annonce aux semaines
dans le poêlon à ficher moncel
combattons un petit peu la kinect vers
la descente à ce que je sois dans le
rouge voilà parfait certes il est jugé
bon c'était plus de 7000 bonne année et
mis à mal et tu me tiens pas l'air bon
c'est parti la suite coûte que tu n'aies
je suis trop des des gens je peux pas
faire le troisième je suis devrait
générer ce truc va regarder des trucs
nul et aux arènes d'eauze bet all
l'enregistrement vidéo était à tout
traitement non rose obtint j'espère vous
avez vu quand même le 8 juillet makan a
haussé ses traits qu'on a je me sentirai
trop bête a fait pleurer non sans rien n
est pas un mais six tiroirs quitté dubaï
et la silhouette
bon on va dire ça les gens et c'est fini
parce que là je suis belle et en plus je
suis dégouté je vais voir si ça marche
ou pas me sont trop cons on voit les
mouvements rapides hier leipp amour dieu
avec le casque qui sont les gueules à un
certain style oh oh [ __ ] allez c'est
parti
elles sont mariées ou est ce que c'est
mais tout le monde revient dans une
nouvelle vidéo oui là c'est l'heure
d'aller manger liam docomo ces métiers
du labrador
[Musique]